awesome all right welcome everyone to a
news stream Grand Masters Choice
um last week we did some tactics from my
games and we're actually gonna follow
the theme with some of my more I would
say recent games some of them are not as
recent some of them are recent so we're
just gonna have some fun stuff a lot of
tactics you guys probably know
how I play Chess at this point it's all
tactics and sacrifices and stuff so
we're gonna be we're gonna be uh
continuing that theme
some of this stuff is going to be easy
maybe but some of them are going to be
complicated so let's let's get at it all
right so here I'm playing with the white
pieces
this is this was actually played in St
Louis back when I was in I am chasing my
GM norms
and it was the very first round of a
norm tournament
so it was very important for me to start
it off well although at the end I didn't
end up getting the jam Norm
um I would say I did have a decent shot
at it back in the day
um and yeah we got to this position
somehow I was playing with the white
pieces and it was from the Karo Khan and
here my opponent played this move
C5 so
this is a very thematic way of
proceeding with the white pieces so I'm
just going to let you guys calculate
basically until the very end
and um yeah this is just a warm-up so
it's just going to be more about having
fun and just calculating stuff
to your best ability just because it's
warm up doesn't mean that
um you have to assume it's easy or if
you can't solve it it's not a problem
but if you solve it very quickly as well
it's just uh
it's great it's good to know that you're
very sharp but
there is more and more to come so take
your time
and um
yeah we're gonna we're gonna get at it
so Knight takes D7 is the first
suggestion and that's exactly what you
should start instantly thinking about
um yep the bishop F6 line suggestion is
perfect it's actually exactly the
solution we're looking for so
that's great that's great um I remember
you guys from the last week but let's
let's kind of address what's wrong with
Knight D7 I mean not that there is
something concretely wrong
um other than
other than black recapturing with the
Knight and they're actually not losing
on the spot at this point so
yeah most of you are getting it in the
chat but for the for the viewers maybe
assuming that Knight D7 looks good
because after Knight takes Knight we
don't really have the attack going on
but but yeah the quick the quick
solution is actually Bishop takes F6
opponent is going to recapture
uh
opponent is going to recapture with the
with the Knight
Rook takes
Pawn takes
Queen G4 check
king h8 and queen H4 this is the
critical move I would say because you're
threatening the F6 Pawn as well as the
H7 pawn and
of course black has to play F5 Queen F6
King G8 and then finally
um
finally The Rook left is the critical
one so
this threatening Rook G3 check and you
can't really stop it my opponent played
F4
there are many ways to win this position
but what is the most forcing
what is the most forcing move you guys
can actually think about
yeah Bishop H7 Rook H3 I also see the
suggestion of um Bishop F6 Knight F6
Rook F6 gf6 Bishop H7 check and then a
rook lift
um
I also see that suggestion this is
possible too and um it totally is is
fine I just thought that Queen G4 is
just more accurate because it's just
like
gives the opportunity to sort of force
everything until the mate so yeah this
is this is relatively easy I would say
all right so the next one
this one has is also memorable I would
say I'm just going to flip the board
real quick
um
yeah yeah Queen G4 looked much more
solid and uh
and um it's just
ends the game immediately so here
um I am
a young boy at this time I was chasing I
am Norms I would say actually I didn't
get my iron Norm in this tournament
um it was in
2011 I believe I might actually be wrong
about it but
I think this was 2011 or maybe
2010 2010 sounds about right actually
yeah I'm playing with the black pieces
against a much higher rated player
actually he was almost 250 points higher
rated than me
um and I believe my last move was night
on B8 to A6 attacking this bishop
and in this position my opponent played
the move Rook e to B1 sort of like
defending their Bishop
it's actually quite logical when you do
it this way because you basically want
to take you they take the knights back
and then kind of like solidify your rook
and then maybe put pressure here
um and you have a very good Center so
it's not as clear what I should be doing
but I think
I did find a nice way of playing here
although
my opponent definitely did have
good ways to defend or better ways to
defend I should say they did kind of
mess it up afterwards a little bit so
let's see if you let's see if you guys
can
follow it up
and then and then I'm thinking of going
into a much more fun game after this
fun in terms of
Beauty I would say
yeah there are a couple of couple of
nice games which we can go over all
right so go at it it's black to play and
how would you proceed
ok
continue that line
continue that line
so the suggestion instantly was of
course The Logical night takes before
Rook takes before Queen D6 attacking
these two guys
Knight takes E4 as a suggestion but
Knight takes E4 F takes E4 it's on the
YouTube chat by the way in id4 fe4 I
don't see the follow-up it's just a free
three nights so Knight takes E4 is not
going to cut it
Queen C3 Rook A3 okay continue that line
it doesn't end
keep it up you're very you're a strong
player so
I think uh I think you can calculate
till the end
maybe Knight H5 is a suggestion
oops
9h5 is definitely a suggestion
um
C3 is not good exactly as you pointed
out Bishop takes E6 you're right it's
not good
um
yeah
so
so yeah this is the line
that was proposed but Queen C3 happens
afterwards and then after Queen C3 Rook
A3 was proposed
um and the twitch chat
is there any Queen sack ideas
um
Queen sack maybe maybe possible of
course you never know
Queen A6 is suggested by Rob
after Rook A3 white has E5 okay okay how
do you proceed after E5
it's a good move strong
E5 Knight D5 yes yes
okay okay
all right so there there are quite a lot
of suggestions but
there is one that's going towards
something and um about first simple
preparing for a simple
simple what preparing C3 how do you
prepare C3
so here like the main suggestion I would
say is this queen D6 Queen C3
oh Queen E7 you mean well Queen E7
in any situation Queen D6 is better
right because you're attacking these
guys when you put the queen on E7 you're
just attacking The Rook at least playing
this
actually helps
um to attack these two guys at the same
time
so obviously if E5 you pick up the Rook
if Queen B2
oh okay okay okay this is what you're
suggesting queen to queen to D7 all
right okay that's what you meant I see
um and what's the idea if I let's say go
for now let's say I go here
because I know you're threatening C3 you
just want to go C3 here right
yeah and then let's say let's say I play
here I'm not sure if we are
immediately winning
now it takes Rook takes yeah
I mean this looks promising from black
too
you can sack The Exchange but he's going
to take it back with the Rook
um but Queen D7 definitely definitely an
interesting move and I'm not saying it's
bad or anything it's it's definitely a
move
what I did was I took and then played
Queen D6 attacking the rook and the pawn
and my opponent played Queen to C3
defending both the pieces
which is logical and that's why I was
asking to continue the line because
here actually is the trick where we kind
of
have to rely on the moment we play
Knight takes before and then Queen D6
and that is Rook to A3 so I'm attacking
the queen which is very critical
if you take my Rook
I'm going to take on D4 and then I'm
gonna win the Rook on A1 because the
bishop is in between the queen and the
Rook
so what my opponent did is he played
this mode of Queen to B2
what he his intention is initially he
couldn't play Queen B2 here
because then I go C3 I went right
because I am forking the queen and the
bishop however after Queen C3 Rook A3
Queen B2
if I go C3 now my opponent's simply
going to take my rook and this Rook is
going to defend that Knight so I have to
take here but I didn't really win the
game
right because I mean surely I have this
threat and it's probably not that easy
to defend but maybe a move like Rook D1
and after Rook C1 Bishop B3 might just
simply hold
um
obviously there can be tricks and stuff
but at least this is not that clear so
here after Queen B2 how do we proceed
how do we
how do we continue the game
Rook D3 is definitely an interesting
move with the idea to like sort of
attack this guy
and you're threatening C3 so
I like that move actually
um the only sort of flaw to it
maybe not a flaw even it's just is that
this move is looking annoying
um maybe it's not such a huge deal but
um
maybe it's not such a huge deal but it
can be annoying at times right because
it's a fork
um
well if you go on id5 your queen is
hanging Rob
so you can't really do that
yeah
I mean you might be able to go like
C3
hit the queen
this looks like a chaos
um but I don't think this is any good
because if you go there
he's just gonna take
we're gonna take and then he's just
gonna take back right
Brook takes Bishop then C3 yeah
yeah you guys got it
instead of Rook D3 I played Rook takes
I played Rook this yeah in that case
Queen takes as possible but then you
didn't win the game right you just
you're just like playing but
he's gonna take here and then he's gonna
take maybe here
you don't win anything you just trade a
bunch of pieces for nothing
so
what I did instead is I took on A2
you can't take with the queen because I
take your Rook so I'm sacrificing the
world an exchange but after the queen
takes now I play C3
I'm attacking the queen and the Rock at
this and the Knight I'm sorry
and also I'm keeping pressure on this
Rook on B4 at the same time
so here my opponent played Queen B3
I took his Knight
he took back
and now what do I do
how do we how do we proceed here
how do we proceed in this position Rook
C1 okay King F2
Rook C1 and then Queen takes H2
definitely wins there's better though
there's much better than just winning
the opponent H2
and obviously you should detect this
like during the game so
of course many many ways when there is
no like oh this is good that's bad kind
of stuff but I usually like to be as
efficient as possible if I can calculate
till the end
and this is quite straightforward so
it's not uh it's not too difficult
Bishop takes E4 even more forcing there
is even more forcing as forcing as you
can do it right like what are the
forcing stuff it's like checks and
captures but even more forcing than
checks or captures is checks and
captures right you do both at the same
time so that kind of gives away
everything but that's a check that's a
check and a capture so basically you
take something and you're giving a check
that kind of comes on top of my priority
usually because opponent generally has
to react and here my opponent resign but
if they took the Knight
I would have played Queen F4 check
hitting the king and the rook and if you
defend your Rook I give check again King
E3 only move rookie one and that's gonna
lead to mates very soon
um also line opening for yeah Queen
Knight G4 is also possible but again in
this case he doesn't have to take
the Knight he can just run away but in
the Knight E4 case he kind of has to
otherwise The Rook on detail is hanging
so stuff like that so keep in mind like
if you are looking for a tactic you feel
it look at the stuff that captures
something and gives a check put that in
your priority that might actually help
you solve a lot of tactics puzzles
like again this is many other moves win
like Queen takes H2 is winning that's
capturing a piece knight G4 probably
maybe also winning I'm not sure if it's
like fully winning because of King E2
like Bishop E4 might still be winning
but why not do stuff that wins on
immediately buy more forcing ways so
all right so we're gonna we're gonna go
into this position right
this is not like white two player win
and at no point like in this position in
this current position I'll claim that
this is winning or anything
but um yeah here my opponent played
Knight G6 so the opening phase doesn't
really matter but it came from a
sicilian as you probably all can guess I
was not a GM back then at this point
still I mean I I was an I am chasing GM
Norms
um and this was at the world juniors and
huntymances Russia
and uh playing very strong I think China
Chinese uh was he a Grandmaster I think
he was a Grandmaster at that time
already but if not then he is a very
strong Grandmaster now
so
yeah it's white to play the first move
obviously is going to be everyone's
first guess like
I'm almost sure everyone's gonna write
the move in the chat but it's not that
clear how do you make progress after
that so
just take some time and yeah of course
the first move is like everyone's gonna
type it in and it's like
at this point you probably all know how
I play chess right I just sacrifice
bunch of stuff a lot of tactics have
some creativity behind it and um that's
how I usually prefer playing so
the first move again you're all going to
guess it and it's going to be normal to
all of you but I want you to come up
with an idea or a couple of ideas right
after so I want to at least spend a
little bit more time on this one because
I think it's it's it's a nice game and
it has actually a lot of depth to it so
it would be interesting to see if you
guys can give a line or two or something
about what you're thinking how the game
would develop
from this position onwards it's also
very early on in the opening it's just
move 13. so
and um yeah
we're gonna we're gonna see after what
happens
so yeah the suggestion immediately
popped up in the chat and I takes B5
but how does how does night like would
you sacrifice this Knight takes B5 in
the real game without seeing Until the
End saying oh this is intuitively good
or would you just sacrifice it only
after you're 100 sure I think this is
the critical question to ask because if
someone is asking you why to play you're
probably going to be leaning towards
Knight takes B5 but
I to be honest don't see a way
immediately winning there is no
immediate win so so why is Knight takes
B5 even a strong move if there is no win
plus I give up my Knights but I and I
also open up the a file for my opponent
so there is stuff uh
that needs to be considered I would say
the idea of Bishop A3 attacking D6 with
Q Queen on The Rook yeah definitely this
is a this is an idea
to put pressure there I mean
one issue is
you might go something like Rook C8 and
then put pressure to my knight and it's
kind of annoying I would say
so the suggestion is Knight b5a B5 King
Bishop B5 King E7
F4 with the idea to go E5 and opening up
um
A3 f8 diagonal that's quite interesting
so so the suggestion is takes takes
Bishop takes
ranking here F4 it's quite interesting
with the idea that you want to go E5 on
the next move and then try to go Bishop
A3 stuff the only thing is that Bishop
A3 ideas you have to spend at least an
extra Tempo because the Rook on A8 is
always gonna
sort of annoy your
um
your Bishop coming to A3
and the other idea on the YouTube chat
suggested was
um oops sorry
was the following Knight B5 ab5 Bishop
B5 King E7 and then the move G5 so what
do you guys think
especially the ones on Twitch what do
you guys think is the idea of G5
the idea is written on the YouTube chat
but not on the twitch so I'm just
giving it as an example for for the for
the viewers there Queen F6 exactly
you're threatening Queen F6 mate which
is kind of cute to demonstrate so an iv5
I think it's an interesting move as well
as G5 is an interesting move objectively
speaking I think
um
the better move is F4 as far as I
remember
um this was in 2015. I didn't really
like analyze it with an engine after
2015. but as far as I remember this was
one of the best G5 wasn't like
particularly
um
like
the top choice or anything but just to
illustrate the idea after Rook takes A2
which leads to Checkmate as you guys saw
it's Queen F6 check and after G takes
you can actually take with the pawn and
actually one of the funny debates I had
is in this position do you do you take
with the pawn for the Aesthetics and
like checkmating with the pawn I mean
taking with the pawn or taking with the
bishop more of the aesthetic kind
because this was just like kind of
Bishops crossing over and it's kind of a
nice mate I would say
um
so that's kind of the debate if which
one is the better one but of course the
idea is mainly to prevent stuff like
Queen A5 let's say with idea Queen F6
takes and then Bishop takes
um the sniper Bishops was yeah it's
quite cool I would say so G5 of course
so if you're playing with the black
pieces how do you respond to this right
um
how do you respond you got to go E5
Pawn hundred percent yeah Pawn is good
um someone's asking my rating in the the
YouTube chat my video rating is 2568 as
of right now and the USCF is 26 plus
probably
so
um yeah so E5 was played
E5 and what do we do where do we put our
Queen
thank you
so the queen can go to multiple
different squares
ah
yeah yeah you guys are absolutely
nailing it you guys are very very strong
Queen B4 and you guys are absolutely
right I want to Target D6 Pawn with my
Rook with my queen maybe potentially
Bishop here but also sometimes I want to
go F4 and then if Knight takes so when I
go Bishop takes E5 so I need this Pawn
to be somewhat pinned on D6 so I played
it exactly as you guys said Queen to B4
and my opponent played Queen B6 very
logical too he is sort of Defending
continuing to defend the D6 Pawn but
he's also putting some pressure on the
bishop on B5
um
and
I played the move F4
um
attacking the center putting more
pressure kind of gaining more space and
just flowing like continuing the attack
if Knight takes F4 the idea is
to take Bishop takes E5 right and then
attack the knights I'm gonna attack this
guy so
this just looks like a disaster
um
so
my opponent played the move Bishop A6
and I completely understand this move
because I can't take the bishop
because my queen is hanging
so what do I do
so what do I do
how do I
keep the game going
continue attacking
and A4 definitely a good good choice and
good to see you
Aziz welcome so A4 definitely a very
good suggestion
with the idea that after Bishop takes
you want to take what the pawn I assume
and yeah this is definitely something I
I had in mind
um
and the position still is probably not
yet winning because in this position he
can go this one of King E8 I remember
this when I was analyzing it and King E8
actually is just like
um
holds the position together because you
get rid of this bishop right you don't
want to you don't necessarily want to do
that
so that's not what I did
it's the most tempting move I would say
but
it's not what I did oops
and the engine confirms King E8 is the
way and it actually gives advantage to
the black pieces so
even more dangerous
you say Rook D5 I think right you wrote
Rook D4 but I'm assuming you're
suggesting Rook D5
with the idea of like defending the
bishop laterally and then bringing this
Rook into the attack if the opponent
takes
so that's exactly what I played I played
Rook D5
and Bishop A3 is another suggestion by
the way so Bishop A3
is also
is also up there
um
but it has its own flaws I would say and
I'm gonna come back to this
um actually I don't have to you can just
take with the queen what am I talking
about if Queen takes their skin yeah
there is no mate that's so I don't have
to readdress this I thought there is a
nice nice defense but this is a
this is just how it's done F takes F
takes E5 with the idea to go there to
the king well once again you can simply
you can simply go Queen takes B5 right
and after like Queen takes D6 simply
King E8 or something and there's no mate
there's nothing
um down two pieces also it's not good
because he's gonna take he might try to
like liquidate or get his Bishop in and
then there's not going to be much much
happening
so I played Rook D5 I defend my bishop
and but my opponent is like okay I'm
gonna go Bishop B7 I'm gonna kick your
Rook out
what do you do then like where's your
Rook gonna go to
what do you do then
Rook HD1 Rook E5 yeah so you guys are
you guys are willing to sack everything
FTX E5 well first of all let's address
Rook HD1 it's it's a logical move you
want to improve your Rook right you want
to bring the last piece into the attack
and attack like that
sack the rock yeah so takes takes
let's see you all you all like to sack
stuff let's see how we can
um
deal with this
so you're threatening Rook takes D6 or
something right
I don't remember the exact defense here
as far as I remember
I did not
it is very easy
sack sack May it's easy to sack your
pieces as far as I remember this doesn't
like quite work
also we're not really like
threatening anything right like
I mean we're threatening fe5 maybe right
but nothing more than that so out of
curiosity let's say I take here you take
there I go 96. where's the mate
somebody show me the mate I don't see it
we're down a rook I don't know for what
and we just sacrificed more pieces so
Queen G1 check is possible too but
maybe the flaw to that is like I have
Rook D1 back so at least Y can pretend
like something is going on
but
I don't see what you do after I just
take and go Knight takes on the night
blocks and I just don't see the the way
forward in this position
so
that's one thing
the other thing is
um
what if Bishop takes
okay I guess we got rated
thank you for the raid
Bishop takes E5 will lead to that so it
doesn't win at all it actually probably
loses all my pieces and I would prefer
to not lose all my pieces
um
not sure what the best move in this
position is but this looks strong trying
to trade Queens
maybe it's not that strong but it looks
good at least for now
Maybe
no oh actually look here
I'm not sure if this is good but Rook E1
might be interesting
which is funny because you can't take
that Bishop F6 is mage
that's funny
however
there must be something
Queen C5 is not that great
this is quite funny
oh okay
but but like I can take this and then go
Queen C5
yeah this is just gonna win
no this is not working not
95 and queen E3 where
yeah also possible but
my only like slight issue with that was
I'm not really threatening to win the
pawn because there's rookie one
of course I'm not checking any of this
what the computers so half the stuff I
say might not be valid but
we're just going to assume that some of
it makes sense
so Bishop B7
the other suggestion we didn't look at
was F takes E5 it's possible and I think
this is more serious than this is a
serious attempt I would say like this
position looks quite unclear to me I
don't see like the immediate defense or
anything and there is certainly a lot of
attack potential
um it still is not like
winning probably like the computer might
hold after some stuff like this still
um
but
it's worth countries it's worth
considering it I did something else and
honestly I would recommend this to like
your audience also
um if you have the chance of like even
repeating it the second time you should
go for it I I played Rook back to D2
um I played back to D2 not to D1 but my
opponent played back to A6 so I have the
option to go Rook D5 back and if I
really want to figure things out later
or maybe take the draw it's up to me so
um
he played that so what do we do now how
do we proceed we have to sort of like
bring all the like dots together we have
been playing
G5 and then F4 and then like Queen B4
and all these things and then we
sacrifice the piece but we're not really
like doing much I mean it's it's all
cool but like you don't want to make a
draw and leave nobody wants that after
sacrificing at night and going for
something fancy and then you're like oh
it's a drill
so
we wanna we wanna do better
Rook HD1 is being suggested in the
YouTube chat okay
it's a logical move like you bring your
Rook
yeah Rook HD one everyone is like big on
this move everyone thinks like this move
wins on the spot or something nobody's
giving any lines so I'm just gonna ask
you guys to write a bit more because the
bishop on B5 is literally hanging
and it can be taken with the queen or
with the bishop so
it would be nice to sort of maybe think
without moving the pieces
it's a very very reasonable move yeah
Rook D1
but how do you how does the game go
how do you follow it up until the end
and also what is the evaluation of this
position like is it winning for white is
it like a draw or is it unclear is it
slightly better for why it's slightly
better for black on like
waiting for black it can also be that
maybe I've just been like sacrificing
stuff for for no reason
so
so what do you guys have in mind why are
you sacrificing all my pieces
without
backing it up
yeah we have somebody writing the full
solution
uh better for black black as a bishop
and Rook but has not moved Queen takes
D6 yep yep yep yep that's that's perfect
I'll just call you Wagner
if it's correct great if it's not I'm
sorry
it's close enough right Wagner
so
perfect line absolutely Rook HD1
sacrificing
black winning they say and then yeah so
Rook D1 is the idea is after Queen takes
B5
Queen takes D6 king d8 queen d8 check
Rook d8 Rook takes d8
King E7 Bishop A3 check
volume of King E6 and then f58 so all my
pieces are actually doing something now
like the whole point of my play with
like Knight takes B5 and then pushing G5
going F4 I don't know even the idea of
going like Rook D5 back to D2 so that
the other Rook can go behind it all like
makes sense all of a sudden and all
these pieces are involved in the attack
um yeah sure the other pawns are not
involved but
you don't really need everything else
but this would have been a brilliant end
of course to the game however my
opponent played um the move F6
which
makes sense I would say the point is
after Rook takes D6 they want to go
Queen takes B5
so they don't get this mate with queen
d8 and stuff so they have like room from
F7 to run away I played this move F5
um
with the idea I believe
if you take Queen B5 I take
King F7 is Queen E6 made and here
what's the idea why did I do this
uh let's see
why did I do this maybe check
on the 97
where's the mate though
I'm not buying this
let me see
let me see
let me see oh I have to take King E8
right
and then Rook D7 at the end
that's the crushing not gonna lie like
black can't move their pieces even oh
something like
G6 is also yeah yeah G6 yeah yeah there
we go G6 exactly Queen F7 is coming nice
that's the mate yeah they can't prevent
it so if Bishop E7
much more
resistance I mean it's not really much
more resistance this is also going to
lead to mate
or First bishop A3 Queen B7 Rook design
yeah this is just disaster
this is not how you defend so my
opponent played this move
F6 F5 Rook d8 here I play Queen C4 so
I'm threatening mate attacking the
bishop my opponent played D5 like Last
Resort but takes takes Bishop A3 check
and uh he just resigned because after
King F7
Queen yeah it was some time ago it was a
long time ago I don't remember
everything but uh yeah that was Gigi
however
now it's your turn to find the best
defense where did Black go wrong
I'll tell you there is a defense in this
game somewhere I mean I'll take it as
back as possible but okay so starting
from here where do you think yeah so so
that's that's the question where did
Black go wrong
like it's all nice great fantastic but
there was definitely some sort of
resistance somewhere like it cannot be
that simple right you can't just go
calculate bunch of things and then win
the game
um
in fact there was actually some
resistance
so actually I'll give okay I'll just
make it easier on you guys the
resistance is in fact in this position
where we kind of skipped we said Queen
takes B5
and then we never calculated Bishop to
xb5 because it just looks horrible after
Rook takes D6 but
like there is a way out you don't like
lose immediately in fact you might not
lose at all
this this just looks super scary like
you're gonna play Rook somewhere
discover check and then it's probably
going to be made
but I saw this defense my opponent
completely overlooked it
my opponent completely overlooked the
defense here
um King E8 yeah
that's that's uh that's a perfect
defense actually because now after Rook
takes B6 real Bishop takes B4
Rook takes B5 as far as I remember
Bishop E7
is the move
and if I still remember correctly it's
not capturing on E5 which I would expect
I mean I'm gonna recheck it I think it's
F5
yeah computer gear does give F5 if I
remove the
the thing like The Arrow and here it
says Bishop E7 yeah this is correct I
remember it correct
and F5 it's not capturing on E5 but it's
this when the idea after takes on G5
check King B1
um 97 Bishop takes E5 is clearly better
for white it's not winning or anything
but it's
0.9 apparently
um but I don't know if he had a better
defense before
as I said it was long time ago but yeah
this whole sequence with Queen B4 F4 was
was definitely good yeah
so that's that game
all right you guys are doing great
actually all right I'll show another one
and it's gonna be
it's gonna be this one
let me just
I'm just gonna ask you like
this position
all right
so why to play
um sort of want to show this position
and then kind of maybe go back and then
show the rest if needed but at this
position is white to play and um
it's one of my
one of my favorite games I would say I
was already a GM at this point
um
that end game yeah the previous end game
definitely is scary for black but that
was like his only defense at that point
he didn't really have much of a chance
but yeah this is one of the games I
really enjoyed
enjoyed playing
um
it was another GM Norm tournament this
was a I was already a GM at that point I
was one of the GMS
so yeah Black's last move is highlighted
is Bishop to D7 from Bishop to C8 to D7
yeah take your time this is this is
quite a quite a good one I would say
um it's not it's not horribly difficult
or
anything it's just
it's just nice
Rook H7 is tempting but risky yeah
that's why I like try to try to see as
much as you can
um
but yeah there is quite some stuff to I
would say calculate it's not
probably not that obvious but it's nice
stuff
foreign
suggestions I'm not going to say it's
correct or wrong because obviously like
some one of the suggested moves are
going to be correct but
there's obviously a hanging Pawn
and then there's also this move Queen C7
trying to trade Queens with the idea of
like playing a great uh
great end game and then B3 is another
suggestion like you can't go wrong with
B3 is another suggestion because you're
just too solid so all of those all of
those moves listed are actually quite
logical
um
but yeah I'm not gonna spoil the Party
by saying oh this is correct that is
wrong or whatever
I think they're all good the reality is
there is not one correct move in this
position so it's just
how my perspective was at that game and
at that time and so on
um
but yeah
let's see let's see if anyone's gonna
like give a complete line or anything
like cool like that or it's just gonna
be like a one line one move
recommendation it can be either I would
say
this wasn't St Louis yeah this was
another
Norm tournament
I have four F5 Rook F1 yeah
uh for context also the black pieces
can still Castle they never moved the
king
all right
there are too many moves yeah that's
right that is correct
Queen C7 Queen C7 Rook C7 Rook d8 Rook
EC one okay
that is a
that's a sensible continuation maybe
kind of
so
it's somewhere there
so
I'll give a hint the hint is that none
of the moves mentioned in the chat is
the move I played
I mean all of them make sense but it's
none of them
I think it's time to reveal that is none
of them so it's not Queen C7 it's not B3
it's not Rook H7
it's not F4
it's not Rook F1 either
so it's neither
so what logical move in this position
Knight D7 is not that either
so we're playing Guess the move
it's not Knight F7 no but you guys are
just throwing moves and I'm happily
saying that's not the move
so I'm I'm curious who's gonna write the
move
I feel like someone's gonna ride it out
of just run like you're gonna run out of
logical moves right at some point
you're going to run out of legal no
soups
so what is it
it's neither none of them
I I don't
as far as I remember again this was like
20
18 or something the move I play was the
top move
I think
we're gonna we're gonna verify it as
soon as we as soon as I say what move it
is I'm gonna show
exactly
I'm pretty sure nobody mentioned the
move I'm checking like both YouTube and
twitch Rick H3 now let me check it again
I don't know if I can scroll I don't
think so though like I feel like I I
drew all the highlighted mode like all
Dimension moves they're all on the board
so if there is a move that you suggested
and I did not draw an arrow for please
let me know I might have missed it but I
don't think so I feel like that's all
the suggestions
Knight G6 no no he just takes it my G6
he just takes
all right come on you guys can do it
I like it these puzzles are funny like I
mean you guys suggested all the best
like logical A3 Queen D3 no
96 no 96 sorry no
A3 no 1966 no
um what else
Queen D3 now
oh somebody's on to something
somebody is actually recommending some
logical stuff
but they haven't really suggested a move
so
King E3 yes King E3
that's what I played
hi viraj welcome yeah King E3 is the
move actually
the point is that
I I do want to play Queen C7 but
I don't want them to like take Rook to
xb2 right like I just don't want that
it's check
I also love to take on H7 but like again
there is all sorts of like Rook takes B2
check again like I don't want to be
under check I want it to be my move
so I'm just going King E3
and like
for sanity check I'm just gonna turn on
the engine and let's see what the arrow
is going to point at
uh yeah see it's still King E3 like the
moves actually
evaluation did not change right it's
still the best move I mean okay the
other moves win too but if you have such
a fancy move right like
King there so why would you not uh why
would you not play it and just to give a
little context the reason I didn't like
mention how this game kind of came there
is that my opponent's like last move was
one move before that was Knight takes
here
and then uh
I just played King takes D2 so kind of
leading up to King E3
um
of course there's actually stuff to
calculate so I just made you guys like
yes and everything but you do have to
calculate F6 when you're playing King E3
and this is actually what I did during
the game before I played King E3 because
if there is nothing concrete um then
King E3 would be like silly so
that was my whole point when I played
King E3 I sort of knew my opponent is
going to go something like F6 for
example if they played something like G6
I would say like defending this Pawn
I can easily play Queen C7 and imagine a
situation like this where these are not
necessarily the best moves but you you
get a position like that they're just
busted they can't move at all and then
you're just gonna figure out how to win
the game like you're putting pressure
there you might just reroute this knight
from oops
G4 to F6 if you really want to you don't
have to this is weak that's weak this
Rook can come from here there and then
invade there and then pick up this one
maybe I mean oops so they just can't
move like there is no way but it's just
to limit counter play King E3 but what
after F6 they're attacking the Knight
yeah I did play King E3 in a classical
game
I mean I like such stuff you know
encounter intuitive I mean it's not even
counterintuitive it's just getting out
of checks Rook H7 is the suggestion yeah
so what happens if Rook H7 Rook takes H7
what do you how do you continue
just needed another hour guessing motion
now you would have came up with um you
would have came up with King E3 at some
point Queen G6 very good yeah Rook takes
eight seven this is critical and then
here my opponent resigned but the point
is after Rook takes we go Queen to G6
check which wins the game on the spot
because if king f8 queen F7 is made if
King d8 Knight F7 is Fork you win the
queen
so the only thing left is actually
king
um E7 where you go Queen F7 check
King has to go to d8 and here you go
Queen G8 check notice the king can never
step on the C file if King ever goes to
E7 then Knight G6 is mate
and if the bishop blocks then you go
Knight F7 check they can't take it
because of the pin and then you're gonna
win the queen next moment in the night
The Rook is hanging
and yeah my opponent resigned after Rook
87 and this actually came from the most
boring opening in the world it was a
London so
that kind of shows that you can still
get a lot of fun stuff
um coming from this opening
and yeah it was a London but I like to
play my London
very dynamically so
yeah
it was it was definitely a fun stuff and
yeah King to E3 this is one of the one
of the highlights I would say
um of my
career I mean it's not like the best
game I played but a king move that's
positional and it's very strong
um is is I would say something that made
me super happy and um
yeah you did you did join
in the very end of the stream but
I'll be around many more times so
hopefully I'll see you all in the next
streams but until then
I wish you all a good night good evening
good morning wherever you are and I'll
see you all in the next stream so until
then take care and see you later
[Music]